is this situation under control
i think you're referring to the fuel
situation and it's it's stabilizing like
there's enough fuel in the country there
always has been what we've seen in the
last few days is trouble in terms of
getting that fuel to the pet for four
courts i think in most parts of the
country it is certainly seeing signs of
stabilization but i think it's also
right as a precaution that the the
government has asked the military to
help i think that starts from monday i
think that's the right measure to take
to make sure people have all the
confidence that they need
as a precaution i mean have you tried to
get petrol
any time over the last week
well i personally haven't tried but my
wife and my as members of my family have
and and of course depending on where you
live it hasn't been easy there there
have been cues i've also heard again
whether it's from family and friends and
and others that the situation is
stabilizing in in most parts of the
country and the measures that have
already been taken in terms of relaxing
some of the rules around hev drivers uh
and relaxing the competition rules so
there can be better coordination between
the fuel companies i think these are all
helping but it is absolutely right i
think that the government thinks about
what more can be done because you know
people want the situation to go
completely back to normal as soon as
possible it's heading in the right
direction but if the military can help
them we should certainly take up that
offer of help yeah the problem is what
what the government never seems to
accept over the last week is that this
is absolutely chaotic you can drive
around and and never see a petrol
station that's open
yeah i i've i think government ministers
of the last few days have accepted the
situation
as it is but what they have done is uh
responded to that in every way that we
possibly can and and it's also important
i think for people to know that there's
never been an actual shortage of fuel in
the country there is enough fuel for
everyone and i can understand why people
so perhaps seeing the scenes on whether
it's through media or or social media
and reacting it's in the way that they
have i think that's a been a perfectly
normal reaction but i think it's worth
reassuring people that there is enough
fuel in this country the situation with
drivers is improving and now if the
military needed to help they will be
ready to do so from monday
yeah i mean it's again saying the
military's there is a precaution i mean
you've got soldiers on uksb given 30
minutes
notice to move at the moment to head
from their barracks to to start on this
job i mean that's an urgent situation
any soldier will tell you that
well my understanding is that the the
military
won't be directly involved until monday
and the reason for that is to give some
time for for some of the extra training
that's going to be required it also
gives time to coordinate uh with the
fuel companies and with others and i
think that makes sense but i think it's
also
really important that we can actually uh
call in the military at a time like this
for that extra support to give that
confidence and and have this uh as a
measure that's there as a precaution
because as i say the situation is
stabilizing no one's going to pretend
it's completely back to normal i wish it
was but it's is it's getting in that way
but i think having the military
available in this way is a really
sensible uh
thing to to think about what about these
these foreign drivers being brought in
and obviously the move to get several
thousand and five thousand i think it
was i mean it hasn't seemed to have gone
down very well with drivers
on the continent why is this move do you
think to get 300 people temporary visas
emergency visas immediately why is that
going to make a difference
of course we've got a everyone knows i
mean this is about a shortage in hev
drivers in particular i think there's a
shortage of around 70 000 drivers in
total in the uk by the way in in europe
in mainland europe there's a shortage of
some 400 000 so this is a an
international problem not just something
uh in the uk and uh it it's right that
we try to find ways to get more drivers
and
forgive forgive me for jumping in but if
there's foot if there's a if it's a a
continent-wide shortage why on earth do
you think we're going to be able to
tempt them over to this country when
we've obviously kicked a lot of them out
of course there's a competition uh for
drivers and that's taking place
throughout europe
but it is important that we try to do
what we can and i am confident actually
that with the with the temporary visa
changes that have been announced that we
will get more drivers but that's not the
long-term answer to this we obviously
need more drivers trained uh to do this
and some of the measures that have been
taken in terms of how that training is
done you know how quickly uh those uh
the training process can proceed i mean
these are all the right measures but in
the short term i think it is right to
try and see if we can get more drivers
and i think that will work
why hasn't
anything been done on this sooner i mean
we we've known this was coming there was
a shortage of drivers pre-pandemic
obviously the pandemics made things
worse some argue brexit has made
things worse
um
and we've had a shortage on supermarket
shelves for some considerable time so
why wasn't action taken prior to this
well there has been a action that's been
taking place as i understand it for for
months and indeed for well over a year
but the one thing you know no government
uh controls is is you know how labor
markets move exactly we all know that
this for example has been tied up uh
with the pandemic across the world but
if you look at the impact on europe and
the lockdowns that were that were had
and the different types of support for
the labor markets from the different
governments in europe it's it's had an
impact that isn't entirely always uh
predictable but you know as we've
as this problem has uh got worse in the
last few weeks and the government has
responded in the way it has with some of
the measures that we've just talked
about i'm confident that there will make
a difference and you started off again
asking about the military and i think
it's right in a situation like this
that we can call on the military for
this type of support and as i say that
will be ready uh from monday and i think
that will further help to stabilize the
situation and give more confidence and
that's the important thing
can i ask you about women and girls and
their safety in the uk the prime
minister said he's uh he finds it
infuriating
the the the police's failure to tackle
violence against women
is this a police issue i mean is there a
fundamental problem with how police deal
with this i mean you were home secretary
you've dealt with the police
you know in great detail
you know i think um that we all the
police are there to protect us and what
i saw as home secretary day in day out
the police were doing an amazing new job
looking after the british people
protecting people i i saw things that
they did you're quite heroic things that
has saved lives your countless number of
lives
across the uk but it's because of that
because they're there to protect us that
this crime this appalling crime has has
had the shock uh that it has you know
across the country and rightly so
because we no one would have thought
that a police officer would be capable
of this and and that is why i think it
is right that there needs to be reform i
couldn't tell you today exactly i wish i
could exactly what that reform should be
i think this should be looked at
properly and carefully and the police do
need to be part of that reform
i mean in terms of that reform we're
talking about a societal issue here
aren't we one of the papers this morning
talking about um exposure i mean
flashing as we always used to call it
being endemic
in this country now and obviously that
potentially being you know
a precursor to other offenses i mean
what do we need to do in society to
change the attitude of those people who
are
who are putting women and girls at risk
look i don't i don't think there's one
single answer to that but it's a it is a
very very fair question i i think for us
to ask ourselves as a society and you
may know you know a few months back
before i came back into government i i
did a whole piece of work and research
into into child sexual abuse and
exploitation and that includes your
children obviously boys and girls uh
that were being abused by by adults and
there are many reasons for the increase
in that abuse and one of those that i
identified and there is more action
being taken on this is is the the the
online nature of your sexual material
whether that's illegal pornography or
even how boys in particular can access
legal pornography now the government's
online harms uh the bill the the work
that we're proposing there will make a
difference but i mean that's just one
thing that i think that we need to take
more action on
yeah i mean it's interesting are you
with the view that which we've heard in
in the past when it comes to these
sensitive issues i mean a lot of people
say we need to lock it away we should be
we should be banning this pornography or
banning all this sort of stuff and
putting it in a box
is is that the right approach or do we
actually need to open it up a bit more
so we at least are having
discussions we're talking about feelings
we're talking about behaviors and
intimate behaviors and what is right and
wrong and acceptable
i think actually it's it's all of that
and you know obviously illegal
pornography is already by definition
banned uh but what is happening is uh
more work to make sure that those
those those predators that try to access
that kind of um online activity are
prevented from doing so there is an
issue around legal pornography access by
underage uh people and the government's
proposals in the online harm's white
paper to to have some kind of age
related access to that i think is a step
in the right direction but there are
there are so many things here that you
know many of them in train i think the
government has taken some excellent
action on this for example the strategy
that was published here this summer on
violence against women and girls the
straightest
safer streets uh funding to having more
police officers on the street i mean all
this is about uh making everyone feel
safer and i think you know after this
terrible crime and and how the whole
nation rightly so has been impacted by
it we do need to think again and
redouble our efforts where does it leave
you as a as a
you've got
girls i i believe um
where does this leave you as a father i
mean with the idea of i mean i don't
know how old your children are but you
know
when they're teenagers or or early 20s
or whatever i mean where does that leave
you in
in in considering how safe they are just
going out going to see friends going to
the pub i mean what what concerns you as
i i've got as a as a human being
i'm the proud father of uh four children
and that's uh includes three girls
including two teenage uh girls and and
uh you know i think as any parent in the
country
over the last few days especially
after this verdict i think we would have
all thought about our own families and
what needs to be done but i think i'm
just with every other parent in the
country um you know thankful uh for our
police in the work that they do to keep
us safe including my daughters and
everyone else but also um asking about
the the reforms uh the police can make
and asking them to show the leadership
that is necessary to make those reforms
and i think they will be coming forward
with reforms but working with the
government i think we can learn from
this and make things better